pierre laurin journaliste écrivain
spécialiste de l'ex urss
pierre laurin vous avez écrit de
nombreux ouvrages notamment un livre sur
l'ukraine qui vient d'être réédité aux
éditions bartillat l'ukraine une
histoire entre deux destins on a évoqué
c'est deux conférences de presse
séparées qu'on attend ce soir alors
qu'en 2018 angers 2010 6,8 entre donald
trump et vladimir poutine y avait une
conférence de presse commune
comment est ce que vous vous analysez le
fait qu'il y aura deux conférences de
presse séparées
je crois que c'est l'une des
caractéristiques de joe biden de
préférer être seul plutôt que dans une
conférence de presse avec d'autres
dirigeants parce que disons que il
préfère avoir la possibilité de se
concentrer sur ce qu'il dit
plutôt que de jouer au ping pong avec
les autres d'autres pas il me semble
également que c'est un format qui
correspond mieux à la situation présente
il est hors de question quelles que
soient les avancées qui seront faites et
il est probable qu'il y aura des
avancées parce que sinon le sommet
n'aurait pas eu quelques-uns des
avancées qui seront faites il et il
serait contreproductif pour les deux
dirigeants d'affiché soudain une bonne
entente de de plaisanter au cours d'une
conférence de presse commune de se taper
se donner et tape dans le dos et passe à
ce qu'il faut là c'est faire en sorte
que les choses se passent le plus
lentement le plus doucement possible en
particulier pour ménager l'opinion
américaine
l'opinion américaine est très hostile à
l'égard de la russie même si
actuellement il ya un renversement qui
est en train de se produire grâce à
l'action d'un certain nombre de
républicains mais les choses sont très
fragiles donc bye donne n'a pas du tout
intérêt
vis-à-vis de sa politique intérieure a
montré qu' il s'entend bien avec poutine
même si c'est le cas je ne peux pas dire
que les deux hommes soient
particulièrement hostile l'un à l'autre
ils se sont rencontrés par le passé
certes ils ont eu des mots plutôt dur en
particulier byden pour poutine
mais tout ça c'est un peu la surface à
l'intérieur il ya des intérêts beaucoup
plus important est qu'ils sont en train
de se dessiner aujourd'hui lors d'un
sommet de l'otan lundi dernier joe biden
a également insisté sur sa volonté de
soutenir la souveraineté de l'ukraine
qu'elle pourrait être la réponse de
valdimir poutine à ce sujet la réponse
de vladimir poutine est très simple à la
souveraineté de l'île de l'ukraine n'est
pas en cause
la russie ne met pas en cause
souveraineté de l'ukraine et la
récupérer un territoire qui appartenait
historiquement à la russie qui est la
crimée qui s'est trouvée par un hasard
des circonstances en ukraine pendant une
période de quelques dizaines d'années et
ça s'arrête là il n'y a pas d'autres
revendications
les indépendantistes comment les appels
du donbass ne sont pas du tout les
indépendantisme ce qu'ils veulent c'est
une autonomie à l'intérieur de l'ukraine
est en cela la russie les soutiens mais
il ne s'agit pas pour le dunk basse de
proclamer une quelconque indépendance et
encore moins de demander un rattachement
à la russie je crois que ce qui s'est
passé ces derniers mois c'est une
incompréhension de la part des
ukrainiens eux mêmes c'est à dire que
ils ont imaginé après l'élection de joe
biden à la présidence des états unis que
il allait obtenir un blanc seing des
états unis de l'europe et de l'otan pour
récupérer les territoires du donbass et
or ce n'était pas du tout dans les
intentions des états unis et les états
unis se trouve aujourd'hui dans une
ambiguïté parce que d'un côté ils sont
obligés de recourir à la phraséologie
habituelle
défendre la souveraineté etc alors qu'en
fait ils savent très bien que la
solution au conflit est très clair il
s'agit d'appliquer les accords de minsk
et les accords de mines ce que ne
prévoit pas grand chose en dehors d'eux
bien entendu une stabilisation du front
du front des élections libres dans le
deuil basse sous contrôle international
et surtout une autonomie
quelle qu'elle soit et il n'a pas besoin
d'être très large mais une autonomie en
particulier linguistique pour les
territoires du donbass et pour d'autres
territoires d'autres nationalités qui se
trouve à l'intérieur de l'ukraine et qui
sont à peu près dans le même cas un
parti n'y a pas de conflit armé
mais par exemple la hongrie et la
pologne font exactement la même chose
que la russie il donne des passeport
hongrois ou polonais aux ressortissants
ukrainiens qui se réclame de ces
nationalités là il n'y a pas de
réellement de problème avec la hongrie à
la pologne en revanche il y en a avec la
russie pour une raison très simple c'est
qu'effectivement il ya une zone de
conflit de conflit armé
je crois que maintenant les choses sont
relativement claires effectivement
défendre la souveraineté de l'ukraine
tout le monde l'exigent
ok les urnes les européens les
américains en revanche faire entrer
l'ukraine dans l'otan
il en est hors de question pour le
moment c'est l'idée des lignes rouges
donnent qui l'a dit lui même
l'une des lignes rouges qui sera évoqué
très certainement cet après midi du côté
de genève
merci beaucoup pierre laurin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes écrivain spécialiste de l'ex
urss et auteur de nombreux ouvrages
notamment l'ukraine une histoire entre
deux destins aux éditions bartillat
livre qui vient d'être réédité
merci à vous pour toutes toutes ces
analyses
un autre